حمله اقالات واستقالات تعصف في اوكرانيا
طالت عددا من المسؤولين الاوكرانيا على
خلفيه فضائح فساد في حكومه الرئيس بولو دي
ميرسي لاندك قام باقاله كاريل لوتي
موتشينكو من منصب نائب رئيس مكتبي في ذات
الوقت اكد مكتب المدعي العام لاوكرانيا
اقاله اوليكس سي مونيكو من منصب نائب
المدعي العام بناء على طلبه والى جانب
اعلان الحكومه الاوكرانيه
في قضيه فساد قدم نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
شراء الموارد الغذائيه للوحدات العسكريه
الاكرانيه اذا ما يقوم به الرئيس
الاوكرانيه قد يضعوا بلاده امام اسوء
السيناريوهات مثلا وابقى مراقبين فانا
ظهور ملفات فساد في وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه والاقالات والاستقالات التي
طالت مسؤولين كبار يمكن ان يضعف حماس
الغرب في دعم الجيش شكرا في المرحله
المقبله خصوصا وانزال بانه لن يتم التقاضي
عن الفساد الذي يمثل مشكله مزمنه في
البلاد وتعهد باتخاذ قرارات رئيسيه بشان
القضاء عليها هذا الاسبوع في خطوه
لاستماله الغرب في مواصله دعمك بالسلاح
القراراتهم تتعلق بشؤون الموظفين بعضها
صدر اليوم والبعض الاخر سيستر غدا بشان
المسؤولين في الوزارات من مختلف المستويات
وهيك للحكومه المركزيه وكذلك في المناطق
وفي نظام انفاذ القانون